des soldats au garde-à-vous posant
fièrement devant le drapeau de
l'azerbaïdjan le ministère
azerbaïdjanais de la défense n'a pas
tardé à dévoiler ses images dans la
région dissidents du haut karabagh le
district de latchine passer désormais
sous pavillon azéri défilé de voitures
les couleurs bleu rouge et verte
il s'est fièrement sous le regard
méfiant de la population locale certains
ne sont pas prêts d'ailleurs à quitter
leurs terres nous continuerons à vivre
ici nous avons un supermarché un modèle
et une maison nous allons les développer
continue à vivre ici comme nous l'avons
fait auparavant
nous n'allons rien donner à personne il
y aura des difficultés mais nous les
surmonterons et je ramènerai ma famille
nous vivront ici tout ira bien
s'accommoder d'un accord de paix sous
l'égide de la russie
les soldats russes bien présent et des
plus prudents notre mission est
d'assurer la sécurité des civils qui
conduisent leur véhicule dans le
corridor de latchine nous disposons d'un
registre spécial dans lequel nous
inscrivons l'heure de passage et le
nombre de passagers
nous assurons également la sécurité tout
au long du corridor
après le district de cale bajard celui
d'acs dames c'est au tour d'une zone des
plus stratégiques d'être rétrocéder à
l'azerbaïdjan au sein du district de
latchine se trouve donc le corridor de
latchine une bande de terre de 5 km de
large qui relie l'arménie le haut
karabagh où la libre circulation est
garantie par les forces russes
les militaires azéri célébré aujourd'hui
dans leur pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une nouvelle réalité est apparu dans
notre région c'est nous qui avons créé
cette réalité
l'azerbaïdjan a créé cette réalité nous
avons chassé l'ennemi de notaire au
total dans ce conflit les séparatistes
du haut karabagh ont rétrocédé sept
districts
près de 2000 soldats russes du maintien
de la paix ont été déployés dans la
région
unité médicale hôpital de campagne
sans oublier des travaux de déminage
compliqué ce mardi le ministère turc de
la défense a annoncé également la
signature d'un accord avec la russie sur
l'établissement d'un centre conjointe
d'observation le but surveiller le
cessez le feu dans la région